do you think there's a lot more to come
from Robert Muller I have no way of
knowing he's had two years he's spent 30
million dollars I have no idea what he
does and does not have Roger stone is
just hours away from appearing in
federal court you are appearing in court
are you at all concerned well I I feel
kind of violated
I mean I'm accused of a series of
non-violent processed crimes not
conspiracy not not the receipt of stolen
material from WikiLeaks not the
coordination of its release it is
alleged that I was less than truthful
with Congress that's false the political
strategist denies any wrongdoing and was
defiant on Friday despite becoming the
latest target of Robert mullahs Russia
team he's still willing to talk they
leak like a sieve or they conduct raids
on your home to depict you like a
criminal like a drug kingpin when you
have no prior criminal record and you're
not accused of any violent crime but I
shouldn't be allowed to go on you know
the sky news and and defend myself so I
do have a concern about that his
Instagram accounts swiftly mocked Muller
a man whose investigation has led him to
being charged with witness tampering and
lying to Congress about an alleged
Russian led hack of democrat emails
released by WikiLeaks are you willing to
cooperate with Robert Muller well I'm
willing to tell the truth but I'm not
willing to make up stories or bear false
witness against anybody including the
president the president has done nothing
wrong he certainly hasn't colluded with
Russia and therefore I'm not going to
make up false tales about him to get to
ease the pressure on myself but he that
would be perjury are you willing to talk
about the conversations you had with
Donald Trump to the extent that I can
remember them but they are generally
speaking just political gossip how am i
doing in Ohio how
how do you what do you think about
Florida do you think we can really win
Michigan have you seen any polling the
Trump campaign unlike most modern
campaigns didn't spend a lot of money on
polling he is a longtime ally of mr.
Trump who has the power to grant pardons
has the president spoken to you about a
presidential pardon no he is most
definitely not I haven't discussed a
pardon with the president with anyone
who works for the president would you
accept one right now I don't need one
have you spoken to the president I have
not I have not he casts himself as a man
under siege the idea that they had to
you know run a bin Laden like assault
although they used more men in their
assault on my home than they used to
take down bin Laden or El Chapo or Pablo
Escobar try to make me look like public
enemy number one this is an attempt to
poison the jury pool to make me look
like a criminal
they say they believed you would tamper
with evidence I've been under
investigation for two years if I were
going to tamper with evidence which I
haven't why would I wait until last
Thursday it's illogical he is an
operator used to the dark arts of
politics but it's hard to know what is
round the corner and the probe could
wrap up any time
cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington